Speaker 1: Other news, other potential criminal
activity out there.
Last week, actually, in a bonus show segment,
I talked about the fact that you have all
of these fake vaccine cards that are becoming
more and more prominent specifically in North
Carolina at the time.
But it turns out just a couple of days ago.
Customs and Border Patrol in Tennessee.
Confiscated more than 3000 fake covid vaccine
cards.
In fact, it was three thousand seventeen cards
in one hundred and twenty one packages, the
packages were labeled paper greeting cards
used for greeting cards or paper paper card.
We're starting to see and in fact, I think
Schumer came out and said we need a special
task force to investigate these fake vaccine
cards because, yes, this is becoming a very
real problem here in this country.
You know, last week it was, oh, we are the
college students are using it so they don't
have to get the vaccine to go back on campus,
you know, leaving them free to infect others.
But now we find out that the CBP of Tennessee
confiscated over 3000 of these fake vaccine
cards.
Imagine, if you will.
The mentality of these people.
Who say, well, I don't want to get a shot,
I don't want to run down to Walgreens real
quick, I would rather waste my time going
through these dark channels on the Internet,
meeting with a buddy of a buddy of a buddy
behind a back alley somewhere to buy a fake
vaccine card instead of just taking your 15
minutes and getting your shot and being done.
I don't even know I don't even know anymore.
But it's so demoralizing.
To see that this is where our country becomes
and honestly, as more and more businesses,
as more and more colleges move to these vaccine
mandates, we're going to see more of this.
This is not going to go away.
This is something that's going to become even
worse as more places demand to see proof of
vaccination.
And yes, the proof of vaccination is necessary,
that is the only way we're going to stamp
this thing out for good.
And if we continue to let it mutate, we could
all be in store for having to develop new
vaccines and getting those as well.
But these fake vaccines are putting people
at risk.
And that's the real problem with it, it's
not just the lying, it's the fact that your
lie puts the health of other people at risk.
The vaccine card is supposed to be a little
bit of a, you know, security blanket.
It's supposed to be peace of mind, especially
if you go into a place and say, well, these
people have their vaccines, I have my vaccines,
we should be safe.
And now we can't even trust our own neighbors
saying, I got the vaccine, did you?
Is your card accurate?
Is it fraudulent?
This is what they're doing to us.
And there's no reason for them to do this
to us.
The places that have required vaccines in
order to enter them have carved out most of
them, as far as I know, especially the college
campuses definitely did.
They've carved out exceptions for people with
religious reasons why they can't get the vaccine
or people who are immunocompromised, who medically
cannot receive the vaccine.
So it's not like, oh, well, we're persecuting
people who can't get it.
No, we're not.
There's exceptions built in for those people.
There's no need for these fake vaccine cards.
Because every one of these cards that goes
out in the streets puts God knows how many
people at risk.
And there's simply no reason for that.
If you want to go through all that effort
to get a vaccine card, there are much easier
ways.
Much faster, safer, more effective ways to
do it.
And that really is one way, just get the damn
vaccine